salut aujourd'hui est un jour
particulier parce que je ne suis pas
seul je suis accompagné non pas d'un
magicien réellement ni d'un mental il
sereinement
bien mieux que ça un tricheur et
forcément c'est le sujet de la vidéo
mais vous l'aviez vu dans le titre c'est
parti génériques
cet homme ce roi de la triche j'ai envie
de dire c'est maurice d'audace avec mon
pote cool alors maurice il ya une
particularité il ne se déplace jamais
sans un jeu tu vois dire que là il avait
depuis dix minutes je dois 200 euros
déjà je n'ai même pas compris comment ça
se fait c'est ça toi tu es un spectacle
à base morisques ça va être tricheurs
oui que je connais bien
va plutôt bien puisque j'ai écrire
collaboré à la mise en scène de ce
spectacle je dise vraiment des vrais
techniques de triche pas et ça c'est fou
parce que il ya la dextérité qu'il faut
avoir payé le culot durant son spectacle
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à une
caméra qui filme et qu'ils jouent mais
ses mains et ses retranscrit sur grand
écran donc du port rien rater en fait
c'est clair est pour toi le plus grands
tricheurs de tous les temps c'est qui
richard marcus les chars markit il a
triché pendant 25 ans et plus grands
casinos du milan ac plus de 5 millions $
et ça m'aide qui est toujours vivant ah
oui c'est clair mais toujours vivant
puisque je les ai rencontrés via skype
interposés donc voilà et sur son boulot
aujourd'hui à richard marcus tu m'avais
prestige d'une bêtise c'est d'être
consultant pour les casinos pour leurs
systèmes de sécurité
exact que je le mets qui les a arnaqué
ayant des années c'est ça aujourd'hui
lardy et si vous voulez je vous empêche
qu un autre mec qui viennent et qu'ils
fassent comme moi un genre est ce que ça
te dirait de faire voir aux abonnés un
petit peu des techniques de triche on
puisse voir à quoi ça ressemble en fait
c'est toujours un peu nébuleux quand on
dit ouais les mecs qui triche dans les
casinos
on sait pas exactement ce qu'ils y font
tu vois je vais être délicat avec vous
mais je décroche quand même pas trop le
mal de mer voilà et si je vous présente
un mort et 12 da salut si on va
commencer par un truc simple ou par
exemple le tricheur quand canton troupe
est quand le jeu est équipé et bien il
annuler la coupe mélanie la coupe par un
petit mouvement en allant sur la sur la
table par exemple et hop il faisait une
coupe charlier comme ça d'accord on a vu
ça bouge c'est un cas on l'a vu bouger
tu vois up je coupe comme ça et tagué
j'annule la coupe mais le fait de le
faire dans un mouvement tout le monde
ne suit pas et personne voit ce qui se
passe quand on fait et j'ai lu la coupe
en bougeant des jetons et est en bonne
position short de la mission pour me
donne hélas la question c'est comment je
vais vous donner à ces commencé à
distribuer ici ah oui là c'est dessus
c'est intéressant tu vois donc je vais
distribuer comme ça fait un moment donné
j'ai une distrib las et là vous êtes en
train de vous dire mais comment se fait
ce je vous explique en fait j'ai triché
encore une fois j'ai triché encore une
fois j'ai fait une donne en 2d donc tu
te donnes la deuxième carte de la
première voie là réside dans le film
bien nous fait d'accord tu vois si je la
mets face envers regarnir je distribue
le deuxième carte agir il faut pas
casser le rythme au chaud avant il faut
pas casser le mythe eut été intégrés
mais combien d'heures pour j'ai une vie
passionnante je sais c'est ça est-ce que
tu as le droit d'aller dans les casinos
j'ai le droit aurait d'ailleurs je suis
un peut survivre rien c'était vert
orange rouge au choix rouge c'était
interdit plaisir nos vins sont allées
bien toi tu étais en orange
toi t'as jamais triché dans la case non
non j'ai pas envie de finir un climat
péter marteau quoi tu es que d'après toi
aujourd'hui tu m'as bien est-ce que ça a
du sens d'essayer tricher nos équipes
dans un casino venons n'ont aucun aucun
ça sert à rien
et du coup du coup après tu seras
vraiment interdit de casino sachets et
c'est impossible quand on parle de la
triche en parle de la grande époque de
la triche avant tout les technologies
d'aujourd'hui évidemment on vous dit pas
de tricher ne trichait pas ne cherchez
même pas tricher c'est stupide et en
plus c'est inutile donc ces deux bonnes
raisons de battre richert est clair par
contre du coup la triche toutes ces
techniques là aujourd'hui c'est de vie
un arrêt c'est pour ça que tu amènes ça
sur scène on pourrait complètement tout
devient un art de voir ça quand ils nous
expliquent là on parlait de cartes mais
j'étais déjà vu aussi tricher avec des
jetons de poker ça c'est aussi ça c'est
incroyable parce que quand on parle de
triche on pense toujours aux cartes mais
on pense pas ou là tout le reste c'est
clair puisque du duc du coup son son
coup de bluff à lui c'était justement
avec des cheveux quasi la wii et à
comment s'adapter les gens le coup de
bluff de savannah bay écoute merci à une
dernière technique juste pour nous faire
plaisir et la dernière technique tient
un bouton tu connais le beaunois
voilà deux cartes de carte noire
d'accord une carte haut et je vous
emmène vous croyez quoi ok c'est bon et
le truc c'est de suivre la carte rouge
ok facile en hockey parce que ici c'est
noir ici c'est noir mais là c'est encore
noir c'est bête hein donc si on vérifie
une deux trois cartes noir donc c'est
vrai que si tu dis classée noire que là
c'est noir là aussi mais tu dis mais où
est-ce que c'est rouge et basse et très
très simple en fait familles font juste
frotter un petit peu sur la table et du
coup en récupérant une carte rouge
d'accord et quand on affronte une
deuxième fois on a une deuxième et une
troisième fois une trois autres sites a
eu une deux et les trois cartons rouges
normalement tu ne peux pas perdre ne
jouez jamais carte avec moi le pire
c'est qu'en travaillant avec lui avec
mes connaissances en magie en vandalisme
etc
je sais ce qu'il fait quand il fait mais
c'est tellement propre mec c'est encore
plus beau
merci enfin si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur maurice je vais mettre un lien
vers ton site sa part dans la réfection
d'un souci un lien vers le site internet
de maurice comme ça vous verrez ces
réseaux sociaux si vous voulez voir
était pas mal de vidéos sur le site
merci à toi d'être venu je te serre la
main solennellement et ascension je
raconte mes doigts il ya un livre qui
existe sur l'univers de la triche qui
s'appelle je crois 52 façon de tricher
je vais vous mettre le lien dans la
description directement si vous voulez
alors évidemment c'est un livre de
culture générale s'est pas encore une
fois ce n'est pas un livre qui va vous
apprendre à tricher vous inciter à le
faire c'est pas du tout l'objet de cette
vidéo
mais si ça vous intéresse d'en savoir
plus sur toutes les techniques qu'ils
ont développées à cette époque avec un
peu le langage qu'ils utilisaient je
mets le lien dans la description si ça
vous a plu vous faites quoi un petit
pouce en l'air évidemment et le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre on approche du
bout mais je vais pas arrêter en 2017 je
vais vous en reparler très bientôt
rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
k o
[Musique]